hi i'm alana pearce and i'm going to be
answering 24 questions
[Music]
who is alana pierce uh how existential
should i get with this i
am a video game writer i've been in the
games industry for a decade was
previously
games media i'm now working at sony
santa monica studio who you probably
know for making god of war
as a person i'm very sleepy that's
probably my main personality trait
what is alana pierce doing now this one
definitely came from google
uh i work at sony santa monica studio
writing a video game but also in my
spare time
i make youtube videos and do twitch
streams majority of that stuff is all
for charity but i have a wonderful time
doing it in any case
what is alana pierce's hair routine um i
don't
actually do anything so this is hair
that i woke up and brushed but the part
that keeps it white
is a shampoo called vanilla no yellow
it's a purple shampoo that keeps yellow
or orange out of blonde hair
that stuff is what keeps it this tone
all the time
how tall is elana pierce i am five foot
ten which
uh in my mother tongue is about 178
centimeters
where is alana pierce going damn
expect this question today i think i
will probably be working
at sony santa monica studio for quite
some time
but i actually think i'm gonna focus
more
you know in my outside of work hours on
uh stuff like filmmaking like making
short films
making documentaries i think i might
start using my youtube for kind of
slightly more complicated
film-esque formats basically
dream project i don't tend to look at
things
in terms of who is the dream project or
like
you know what is the the holy grail of a
thing that i want to work on people were
asking this
for years when i said i just really
wanted to write a video game and that's
what i was heading towards i kept
getting the question of like well what
do you want to write what video game do
you want to write i care more about the
team that i work with than necessarily
the project that i work on
because if you work with a really good
team of people who are
inspiring super knowledgeable experts in
their field
you can get very involved in any project
it doesn't matter what it is if you're
working with a good team you will love
what you're doing
any project i do i just want it to be
with people who
can teach me a ton of stuff and are
really fun to collaborate with
dream character to portray so i have
more recently got into voice acting
hands off my cop
slowly getting better some of it's not
great some of it i think actually is
pretty good
you cannot scare me i'm too smart for
your little game so stop trying it's
getting embarrassing
but i have two that i would love to do
not characters just voices one is a
valley girl
so like i would do this but the problem
is that i don't know where it belongs in
a video game the other one
is uh the like rock star trailer lady
in los santos you can buy houses like
either of those things i think would be
very fun for me to do
dream character to write to to give the
closest to a real answer to this that i
can it would be someone who is
incredibly different to me and hard to
relate to
because i get very sparked by a
character if i feel like oh i
understand this because i have this
quality so having someone who'd be very
very very different to me
i think would probably be really
exciting and and really difficult
and that's the kind of challenge that i
want in my life
morning routine ah i wake up make a
coffee and work
basically what that looks like is i
guess i do wash my face in there as well
i sleep for as long as i possibly can so
say i have to start work at
nine i will wake up at nine sorry 8 50.
start making my coffee which is just an
espresso so you just hit two buttons go
wash my face brush my teeth
i put some facial oil on brush my hair
that's it so my morning routine is
terrible um and is all about maximizing
the amount of sleep i can have
favorite swear word i don't know if i
can
even i'm not gonna say it because it's
probably
americans will watch this but i do have
a fondness for the c word
because i'm australian brits love it too
it's something that we say really
colloquially
in like a friendly way to people in
australia and i think because of that
it's like emblematic of the whole
country for me and i miss it a little
bit
you can see it i can say it
let me give you an example then so if i
do say it uh the context that i would
usually say it in
never negative is in australia we would
call someone a sick
or a man maybe like he's a sick this
dude
rules he's super fun to be around mad is
very similar it's like
someone who's top quality is a sick or a
man
creative routine hmm i think
probably uh just by virtue of
the career that i've had or just the
professional experience that i've had
my creative routine has sort of just
been
born out of a specific production
background actually
but i tend to look at everything from
the mindset of a producer because i was
a producer at ign and
at funhouse and i also think it helps me
a lot with my job at santa monica studio
to just
think like a producer which really just
means a lot of organizing and for
planning
all of the planning stuff comes in
before the creation stuff and i think
that's probably part of why i am able to
get
a lot of stuff done because if i've
tried to write books and have [ __ ]
been like i'm just gonna sit down and
write uh it never gets finished
so definitely having a lot of structure
yeah my creative routine is ultimately
not that creative it's very organized
what does you will never walk alone
mean to you uh ynwa
you'll never walk alone is a slogan that
is associated with liverpool football
club it's something that if i ever see
somebody wearing a liverpool
shirt i will kind of just yell it at
them which to anyone
else around me especially in the u.s
seems very weird but it's always like
hey we're part of the same club but it's
a lot of fun but i think it's also
um a wonderful song that is about
you know getting through the storm and
knowing that you are not alone in
anything that you do and that there are
always
people with you so it's something that i
think is inspiring just in general but
also
ynwa that's it
what kind of voice would this have
i feel like i'm not going to do this
accent right
but i feel like this dog is a oh hello
sweetie oh what are you doing there
but i feel like there's a minnesota
accent in there i'm not sure why i feel
that way
but i'm committing to game to have the
biggest impact on you
it's a very common answer and i think
that's one of the things that i probably
really respect about it um but to go way
way way back
it's probably ocarina of time ocarina of
time isn't even my favorite zelda game
it wasn't my favorite nintendo 64 game
but i think a lot of people have
moments with ocarina of time when they
realize what video games could do
and i think that i continue to really
appreciate ocarina of time because
we're still living in an era where most
people who are
playing video games have taken direct
inspiration from mockery out of time in
a lot of cases
yeah very impactful game even if it's
not necessarily
my favorite but i feel like you can't
deny the influence it had on the
industry as a whole
and on little tiny alana
favorite song my favorite song is
zombie by the cranberries but i also
have a tremendous fondness for
uh freaks and geeks by childish
weirdest expression of batman fandom
my apartment is very small i live in a
studio apartment
if i did not have
i don't know maybe 50 batman statues
probably about 50 that just are
everywhere i would have so much more
room for other things
to the extent that my clothes are in my
kitchen cupboards
and before you ask well alana what do
you do with your kitchen stuff it is in
other cupboards the truth is just that i
don't have that many clothes
so that i can make room to put them in
the two cupboards that they're in
so my weirdest expression of batman
fandom would be
that it has taken over my entire
apartment prevented me from getting
you know any kind of like cupboard or
chester drawers
uh in favor of having batman merch
everywhere and all of it is very scary
i don't collect a regular looking batman
i collect one that looks like a samurai
or a vampire or a zombie
so i don't know what's wrong with me
favorite batman collectible damn
it's a tough one to answer but i'm gonna
go grab him let me let me just give it
so i'll just be right back you'll see
why he's very bizarre
it would be this kid
people really hate him and because he
sits on you know one of my various
batman shelves
he really sticks out because of the eyes
and the stupid face
i love him um i think he's so weird
and truly terribly painted it's you can
see the paint underneath the eyes like
as someone who's been collecting for a
really long time it's not like it's well
made
i just think it's so cute he's just such
a cute little guy
so also very cheap compared to a lot of
the other stuff that i have but
just this just the strangest thing that
a human envisioned
and slapped batman clothing onto i
absolutely love it
as your american instagram character how
many american presidents can you name oh
i'm not gonna be good at this
okay um um as my again a
valley girl character that i
occasionally do
instagram reels of we've got obviously
donald trump
uh joe biden right now ronald reagan
um trying to go in order and i've
already screwed that up so it's george
bush
there's another george bush um
[Applause]
i miss like a really obvious oat bill
clinton
those are all the most recent ones and
then like everyone before that i'm gonna
sort of just guess and
like i could be wrong so i'm gonna leave
it there
confidently i know those ones are
presidents okay and that's
that's it we'll even get there
first job my very first job was
at mcdonald's i operated the drive
through for the most part
and when i was bored in the
drive-through waiting for people i would
organize all of the notes
in australia our notes have windows on
them that you can see through to
verify that they're real notes so i
would like make sure all the windows
were lined up and just have all the
stacks neatly organized because that job
isn't always that high action and when
it is it's pretty fun
uh did one time have somebody i don't
actually know what they were mad about
or what they
felt like i had done but uh you know
they paid
they went through the drive-through and
got their milkshake and then they came
back through and
threw the milkshake at me so they still
paid for it
um don't remember why it happened but i
ultimately actually really liked working
at mcdonald's very different to what i'm
doing now though
if you weren't in the gaming industry
what else would you be doing i would
just be writing elsewhere i think
my two passions my whole life really
have been writing in video games
uh i found a way to combine the two if
we remove video games i think i would
still just be writing about something
else maybe i would be writing
the screenplays that i'm writing in my
spare time now maybe i would have
published a book
uh just different kinds of writing for
sure
tell us about fairy bread i'm glad you
asked berry bread
is an australian just absolute delicacy
where you have white bread it's got to
be the full preservative
stuff put a bunch of butter on it again
full fat butter and then you put
hundreds and thousands sprinkles yeah
you sprinkle
top of them with those little tiny balls
of sugar that are colored
uh and then you eat them and it's
actually quite nice
i still like it because it's just butter
sugar and bread which
are three of the best things to ever
have existed
but it does seem pretty absurd to anyone
who's not from australia and sometimes
it's hotly contested whether we should
really be giving kids that much sugar
but
we do and it's wonderful
how does woman shoot gun with boob this
comes from
an ins no it's probably an ign comment
that somebody left
um a genuine comment when i worked at
ign
that somebody was basically complaining
about female characters and ever since
then
my friends and i have quoted this
person's comment the kind of like
famous in my friend group of colleagues
who worked at igm
where we we use it anytime anyone says
something that's like
you can't have women in video games so
it's how does woman shoot gun
with boob because you have to say with
that amount of anger as well
can you break an egg by squeezing it in
one hand
listen i've not tried
and i do have really weak hands i
recently got into a motorbike accident
so
this hand you can kind of see there's
like weird scars going on it's still
pretty weak
um and i also have tendinitis in both of
my wrists
so my hands are a bit of a mess
i'm gonna say no but i will call out the
people who make those tick tock videos
where they like break the egg
there i'm built different i could 100 do
that you just have to have the grip
right that's not a strength thing that's
just grip
i could do maybe not the hands but i
could do the arms
i'll take a win francis york morgan
very good very this is this is good
content francis
morgan is the detective from deadly
premonition one
and two uh name kind of technically
changes depending on what part of the
game you're
in but everyone just calls him york he's
lovable and wonderful and
daily premonition is my favorite game
ever thank you guys for watching that
was fun
uh again i'm alana pierce i work at sony
santa monica studios so you can check
them out obviously you might know them
for making god of all
but on the internet i'm known as
charalanazad
pretty much everywhere it's my name in
the middle of
charizard i don't know why i decided to
do that i was 14 we all make mistakes
but uh yeah i do regular charity streams
youtube videos
and a whole bunch of other stuff uh
definitely check out my podcast if you
want to call play watch listen with troy
baker austin wintery and mike bithell
where we talk about the games industry a
whole lot
otherwise i will see you around bye
[Music]